looking at that train that was the
summer of 1980 when I was 23 that New
York City subway was one of more than
5,000 that graffiti artist Steve Ogburn
covered in color captured in photos now
on display at the new Museum of graffiti
and you're doing this in the middle of
the night this is a two o'clock in the
morning
pitch dark standing like this next door
train you got to a point where you
became a master an expert in New York
City subways well in the end of tunnel
is because I could really run really
fast that's six feet tall probably 139
pounds 29 inch waist I mean I could move
for me it's so nice because someone's
recognizing it known as blade he was
part of the birth of modern graffiti in
the 70s and 80s and is considered one of
its pioneers among a generation of
daring young writers whose works are
featured here your intention was what
when you set up the design of the museum
to bring you through a historical
timeline to show you from the very
beginning of the style writing movement
the graffiti art movement till today
Allen ket is a graffiti artist historian
and collector who partnered with former
state prosecutor Allison Frieden as she
was doing advocacy work for graffiti
writers the duo co-founded the museum
not only to educate the public and
preserve the history but to provide
visitors a counter narrative that was
really the goal for both Allen and I is
to sing the song of unsung heroes who
have contributed so much to our culture
yet the artist who pioneered that were
routinely shunned for their work there
was a war on graffiti for four decades
there was a war on graffiti for decades
but what does that even mean that just
means you're cleaning it up that means
that you're incarcerated young kids and
perhaps exposing them to real criminals
and real criminal activity in real
criminal life ket's legal run-ins over
his work landed him a number of lawsuits
done and in 2007 a plea deal with New
York City prosecutors that made
headlines
there still will be people who will
watch this and say that's not art that's
vandalism you know and I think that
those folks that that say that should
come and visit us and take a walk with
me
so that I could explain to you why this
is in art form and how this art form was
created and how its evolved and
developed and gone around the world and
how it now sells for millions of dollars
then you see gesture to the right his J
kicks up and creates a big circle it's
what he's now doing inside the
collection in the early 80s and out on
the streets where the museum has
commissioned 11 murals we walk by and we
see police they're looking for the
artist it's night time they're using
flashlights the institution opened in
Miami's Winwood neighborhood a former
industrial district that over the past
decade street artists have transformed
into a vibrant and massive open-air
gallery here aerosol artists from around
the world have free reign Wynwood really
has become a destination here in Miami
Wynwood is an art destination in Miami
it's awesome entertainment destination
it's a foodie destination there's all
kinds of things happening here it's a
nightlife destination the 3200 square
foot museum is packed with more than 300
pieces of the movement's history and the
artists behind it and I started on buses
artists like Blade who's trailblazing
work earned him the title the king of
graffiti did you ever think this day
would come
no of course not because it's an art
form created by young people for young
people and when I started there were no
masterpieces they're going Holkar top to
bottom and to end some of the artifacts
are from Allen ket's personal archives
for him
the museum's opening
and the celebration that followed is the
ultimate validation when you grow up as
a child and your parents tell you that
this is something wrong and then when
you go to school and your teachers are
telling you this is wrong you're gonna
be a loser for the rest of your life and
society finally catches up to celebrate
you it's incredibly moving it's an
emotional experience you know you never
think that you'd make it to a place that
finally got it Kenneth Craig Miami